In this problem, we want to modify addtoindex
such that a particular URL appears only once for a given keyword.
As the code stands here, if a keyword appears twice in a URL,
the URL will be in the index twice for that keyword,
if you could follow along.
The solution to this is actually really simple and only a single line of code.
First let's go over addtoindex really briefly.
If we want to add this URL to this keyword in the index,
we're going to go through everything in the index,
and when we hit the right entry for that keyword,
as it stands now, we simply append the URL to the URL list.
But we're going to add 1 line of code that says only append to the URL list
if the URL doesn't already appear in that list.
We also need to fix our tabbing--very important--and that's it.